before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
all we get to talk about my favorite
episode of the entire chipmunk Herrera
I blush
foreign
[Music]
that's right folks it's time for can you
hear me an episode that I have argued is
not only the best of the 12th series but
it's the best of the entire chiminal era
I am pretty sure I am the only one who
holds this opinion not everyone disliked
like there was a there was a kind of a
harsh reaction one at first uh it came
out I think more people have come over
to my side but not necessarily to the
degree that I have now it's always
tricky going back and re-watching ones
that I know I like because well
when I watch ones that I remember not
liking or don't remember very well at
all I'm looking for where's the good in
this where's the stuff I forgot stuff I
missed the stuff that makes it worth
anything
but what that means is conversely when I
re-watch episodes that I already like
I'm kind of watching for okay
does this hold up were there problems I
didn't see and
not really
but I can see where the problems that
are in it that do not bother me could
make it a hard sell for other people or
diminish it in some ways but overall
I still really like this and I still
think it's the best thing of the entire
era and uh yeah I'm really here for this
first of all uh it has some of the same
appeal that it takes you away had in
series 11 which is that
it's weird it's weird it is mind-bending
and not like in a super hard to follow
way but like
this bald dude whose fingers come off is
invading people's minds to try and save
his partner in godhood who's trapped
between two planets and tricks that like
it's weird it's weird the overall
aesthetic and the feel and the tone of
the thing is weird and I'm here for it
because it's weird in that ooh there's
stuff going on that's you know beyond
the normal scope of experience kind of
weird as opposed to somebody screwed
this up and like nothing and nothing
tracks at all kind of weird it's not
that it's the kind of weird that I like
so uh it still has all that and I
suppose the big thing that I need to
acknowledge is something that
I've pointed out before being on the
other side of the equation four
um and unfortunately I can't quite put
myself in that mindset here so here's
what I mean by that
I've had instances with other films that
I have taken a distaste to where
sometimes the people defending that film
or that episode of a show will go into
the metaphorical and allegorical
meanings of the thing in order to defend
it
um and sometimes those are even things
that I didn't catch on first viewing
however my normal opinion is that that
does not usually fix the underlying
problem which is that if your story only
works because of the metaphor or the
allegory then you haven't told a very
good story
and if someone were to level that
criticism at this episode I don't really
have a defense against that
because I latched on to this I'd like
when I first watched this when it first
aired I did something I almost never do
I watched it twice before I did my
review and the reason I did that was
because when I finished it the first
time I was like
I feel like I know metaphorically what
this is doing
and I want to watch it again to be sure
that what I'm thinking tracks before I
say it
and so as a result and I am so
comfortable with my reading and we'll
get into that in a minute but as a
result this is something where I can't
really view it through the lens of what
if you don't grasp the metaphor because
at least the one that I read into this I
grasped immediately and is a core part
of my experience of this story so if
anyone is out there who either didn't
latch onto that metaphor or it just
doesn't track or connect with you yeah
this might uh have some more issues or I
guess more accurately the things that
I'll point out as potentially problems
for other viewers are probably bigger
problems for you than they are for me
but what is that metaphor what is that
allegory well it is mental health and
it's very upfront about that I mean the
whole thing opens in Aleppo and it opens
and the doctor later shows up in in
there and pointing out you know it
renowned for its treatment of mental
conditions and mental illness
um that is kind of annoyingly probably
the only reason Aleppo is even there as
a location is just that's the only way
it connects so like that's a little
unnecessary
um and possibly eats up time that could
have been better allocated elsewhere but
that is what is there but like that does
lay out right off the bat mental health
mental illness
depression anxiety paranoia these things
are what this is about
these things are what these two gods
these two selfish maniacal gods
represent
and when we get to that
um sort of animated section you know
telling the story of the two planets
that they pitted against each other
that's what mental illness can feel like
like your own brain is attacking itself
and if you've ever even if something is
as low-key as just that voice of
you're an idiot why did you do that
you're so stupid
just that doubting voice is the low end
form of that in some ways because you're
you're arguing with yourself
and if you amp that up enough to truly
destructive levels
that's what they represent
and they don't represent a person's
brain the two planets do these two
represent
the illness that is pitting that mind
against itself and it is only when
things are balanced properly
be that through therapy or assistance
from medication but only when things are
balanced properly can
those forces be contained not destroyed
not eliminated
but contained and managed
so I still stand by this reading of this
episode and no I haven't read uh like
interviews with the writers to see how
intentional this was or wasn't because
even if this was never the intended
reading I don't care
I can't think of any reason why anything
else would be the intended reading of
this and it works so well that if the
writer of the script or if Chris chibnol
or anybody involved in this came up to
me said that's not what we were going
for with it I would say oh okay well
as far as I am concerned and my love of
this thing you're wrong
like I I I wouldn't know what else to
say so I I do feel that that
integration of those themes and and the
metaphorical level of these malicious
gods and the setup that they're in works
with that and we have the various layers
of this we have Ryan's friend who we saw
initially in spyfall part one who is
struggling
and who feels alone and who Ryan now has
some guilt am I not there for him when
he needs me and so he's going through
something we have this Revelation about
Yaz and uh point from her own past
something we haven't really gone into
detail before but a point in her life
previously where she was in a dark place
and we are on the anniversary of that so
we get flashbacks of that and the
flashbacks to Yaz
um or rather like her sort of dream
memory of that is really interesting
because when we first see that stretch
of road and that cop
that cop's face looks cruel
but then later on we see the actual
interaction
and that's not who she was at all
but that is something that in Darker
moments yaz's mind could twist it into
being which again just fits in with all
of this Graham's connection with it is
probably the weakest because he's not
really dealing with any Mental Health
crisis uh past or present
um not that Ryan is but Ryan has a very
direct connection to someone who does
um
Graham just has some anxiety about his
cancer coming back
um but that's also part of why he's used
as the conduit for the trapped God as
opposed to as much being fed off of him
directly like he still gets his
nightmare sequence the cancer comes back
Grace tells him for some reason he's not
married to Grace
um anymore and she just tells him he is
literally ours to live so like he has
anxiety but also like the episode
doesn't spend as much time on him
because what he's going through well
worth acknowledging and I do feel it is
even at the very end I'll come back uh
to that scene as well
um but you know that's not as deeply
rooted as what Ryan's friend is going
through or what Yaz has gone through
historically so I don't think that's
actually necessarily a flaw that what he
is experiencing and the anxieties he
have are not as much deeply rooted in
potential mental conditions as just a
general health anxiety but it also kind
of serves to illustrate that you can not
have some kind of diagnosed mental
health condition but these things still
play up these things are still going to
be part of your life even if in a more
subdued way there's a lot of
interactions that I like that the doctor
has I like her moments of starting to
talk as if the commands are there that
they're not and they repeat that gag a
couple times I like that I love the gods
a villain especially he is so unsettling
he's so creepy I'd like and especially
just that moment where like there's a
mother putting a kid to bed says there
is no bogeyman closes the door camera
pans over and there he is just standing
there that's not
oh
that's so creepy I love it I absolutely
love it I think the one of the
criticisms that I do think is valid but
does not super bother me
is that the conclusion is rushed and the
defeat of these things is
um happens too fast and
I don't really have a defense of that I
don't think that like it does suffer
from not having basically another 10
minutes I've seen some people say it
should have been a two-parter I'm not
sure it would have benefited from
another full 40 minutes but it
definitely would have benefited from
another five to ten
um that it definitely would have
benefited from and maybe that's where
the
um the time spent in Aleppo specifically
especially since that uh side character
introduced there doesn't really get a
lot of development maybe where that
should have been scrapped to give more
time on the back end to get us to spend
more times with these gods and more time
on how they are defeated so that it
doesn't feel quite as rushed that having
been said I still feel like the overall
way that his resolve still works for me
um even though for how much they are
kind of built up and again I love uh
zilling going on about you know some
beings are just above you doctor and you
know name dropping something the
eternals have their games
the Guardians had their power struggles
this dimension
is a beautiful board for a game
toy maker
we're an upper echelon you're just not
and I also like that his entire trap
plays off of her empathetic instincts
she assumes that because there's this
creepy dude and there's this person
trapped here like he trapped her and now
Zealand very much wanted her to think
that but he's playing on her instincts
to help to get her to do a thing
that is not going to be to her benefit I
think like honestly and this is only
just occurring to me as I'm saying it
I kind of wish these two
were the villains in flux
instead of the sparkly skull people
I'm not gonna dig too much into that
because I'm literally just having the
thought as I'm saying it but I kinda I
kind of would have liked them to come
back and have it be them
I feel like that could have worked
anyways
um moving on from that the other thing I
need to address that is a fairly
frequent criticism is the scene towards
the end between Graham and the doctor
now I've defended this scene at length
if you want I'm going to give you the
quick version here but I did a much
longer version some time ago because it
it struck me as odd that this was such a
big complaint by a lot of people that
like Graham comes to her worried about
his health and she just brushes him off
and they make a joke about how she
socially awkward and that reaction
always struck me as really weird because
never once did I think that's what's
going on the scene and even having
rewatched it I'm like I guess I can see
where some people are thinking that but
it I
I don't know how you end up with that
reading I just I just kind of don't
because
she is opening up to him
in the best way she can at the moment
because
the doctor and her interactions as has
been reiterated in this series in
particular she's
very bad
at opening up to them or at engaging
them emotionally outside of the
immediate moment you know outside of you
know stay calm let's deal with this
crisis she's not great at this stuff she
just isn't
and she's not going to suddenly become
great just because it's Graham and she
cares about him
so rather than just flounder
she's going to tell him up front
I I'm bad at this
so I'm just going to certainly walk
towards the console and look at
something and then
in a minute I'll think of something that
I should have said that is her opening
up to him and saying
I can't be exactly what you need right
now but let me give you some of the
reason why
and know that I care and know that I'm
gonna Circle back because this is the
best I can manage right now and Graham's
reaction from what I can tell is that he
gets that okay
well
I'm glad we had this chat hi
yeah I don't see any callousness in her
reaction it's an unconventional reaction
certainly
but it's still a caring one
because she's recognizing in herself
he's coming to me for someone to lean on
I'm not good for that
and in her own way explaining that to
him in a way that isn't brushing him off
that isn't saying Go away I'm bad at
this it's saying
I should say something reassuring right
now I'm going to fail at that
give me a minute I'll come back to it
this is her caring
I I just I don't I don't get the harsher
reads on this scene I just don't and I
suppose the the other thing that I'll
point out is that as much as people
complain about the resolution of the
villains being rushed
I think
again I think the better choice would
have been to ditch the Aleppo thing but
I would definitely prefer what they did
versus another possibility which is they
don't take the proper time to to deal
with the resolution of these individual
Stories being Grammy as and Ryan you
know having Ryan reconnect with his
friend and be sure his friend starts
talking to people and you can see on his
face you know as he's sharing this story
of you know trying to get out of the
house and connect just in even a little
way so I go to the store and I think
I'll I'll just chat with the checkout
clerk for a bit for a bit and it's all
self-checkout and people in the room not
only kind of laughing at that but also
understanding I haven't said that to
anyone before
felt like it was just me
it's not just you
that scene needed a little time to
breathe and it has it
or Yaz reconnecting with that cop and
giving her the 50 pence
that scene needed a little breathing
room and it has it and I still like the
Graham scene I know other people hate it
I don't I think it plays well
and part of the reason it plays well is
it has the room to breathe so yes
the defeat of these beings is rushed
but not for no reason it gives us this
other stuff that given what the core
themes and metaphor of the thing is is
kind of more important than making sure
the villains are properly threatening
and take a lot of effort to defeat
because this is about mental health this
is about
um you know reaching out both to people
who need help and to people for help and
spending more time at the back end on
that and those scenes is the correct
call and it's the call of the show made
I still really like this
and there's like other random stuff
there's like this this little line I
really like from the doctor I've got
plans crashing through my brain all the
time you want a plan come to me
identifying which time's gonna work that
that the tricky bit and also there's a
line that again just reaffirms that I
don't think I'm reading into it too much
with my interpretation of this you know
the best part of humanity the cruelty of
their own minds directed towards
themselves
and again
that's mental illness
that's depression that's paranoia that's
anxiety
that's your brain turning on itself and
that's literally what he's talking about
I think this is still really good
again I can't really examine it divorced
from the metaphor
I think remove from the metaphor yes
some bits are rushed yes the Aleppo
thing maybe doesn't need to be there and
the character associated with that is a
little underdeveloped again maybe wasn't
necessary but I think it's still a solid
enough story but I also feel like trying
to give an assessment of this thing
minus the metaphorical level is a bit
like I don't know trying to assess the
quality of a painting but not taking
into account the color blue it's it's
it's it's too ingrained in what's going
on uh you can't just remove that but
anyways that's can you hear me
I still think it's really good
you rewatched it lately what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living even if you can't help me out
there there's other things I do links in
the description
um but besides that like share subscribe
also help me out but even if you can't
do that
what I really want you to remember
especially if you are struggling
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
well it's patreon supporter Shout Out
Time folks so thank you to Robin Moore
Zubin lupula to rock the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Angus
bjornison Linda Walters IMU delki Theo
the Boyd toy lowly Becky Sparkman for
Nabi lacks the poodle Zach Tracy scrabot
General contact unit Problem Child angry
gaspro Tim price Adam RDL Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose thanks so
much for your help you can get your name
right out too check out the rewards in
the patreon
what they should do should they check
the paper
[Music]